so i want to sort through this and uh
tell you what i'm
sort of uh thinking i i suspect that you
won't agree with everything i have to
say that's okay
it'd be weird if you agree with me all
the time i barely agree with myself all
the time
but we're all in a position where we
have to pick our way through the weeds
through the misinformation obfuscation
fake news out of context news
all of that as we discussed yesterday
there's a crisis of trust in this
country ultimately
one way or another we get much of our
information about world events and
political events
and the election through the media we
can't trust the media
we can't trust most politicians
government officials so
it makes it very hard to know what's
real and what isn't it requires a lot of
uh discernment on our part a lot of
clear thinking a lot of a lot of
intellectual honesty um and
and that's how i'm trying to approach
this and i think how we should all
try to approach it now president trump
gave a press conference last night the
media went ballistic over it
calling it an attack on our democracy
the worst thing trump has ever done
since the last worst thing he's ever
done uh here's here's how that press
conference began
listen good evening i'd like to provide
the american people with an update on
our efforts
to protect the integrity of a very
important 2020 election
if you count the legal votes i
easily win if you count the illegal
votes
they can try to steal
the election from us if you count the
votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
as i said the media reacted to that the
whole thing the whole press conference
with typical dramatic flair
uh here for just one example this is
anderson cooper
alleged news anchor offering his uh
quite objective analysis
of what trump had to say we have never
seen really
other than i don't think we've ever seen
anything like this from a president of
the united states
and i think it's jake said it is it's
sad and it is truly pathetic
and of course it is dangerous and of
course it will go to courts but you'll
notice the president did not have
any evidence presented at all
nothing no real actual evidence
of any kind of fraud talked about people
putting up papers and windows he talked
about things that he'd seen
on the internet that is the president of
the united states that is the most
powerful person in the world
and we see him like an obese turtle on
his back
flailing in the hot sun realizing his
time
is over but he just hasn't accepted it
and he wants to take everybody down with
him
including this country an obese turtle
i bet he was proud of that line
hilarious stuff nice job anderson
you know i could say that you look like
a cartoon seagull
if i wanted to stoop to your level i
would say that but i don't want to stoop
to your level so i'm not going to say
that
and anyway however you feel about
trump's rhetoric his
his his uh you know in his response his
fraud claims all of that
even if you think it's reckless and
dangerous and whatever else
you absolutely have no standing at all
to condemn trump much less get all high
and mighty about it if you're a democrat
because democrats for four years
accused trump of being an illegitimate
president they said it multiple times
many times over and over and over again
relentlessly
they accused him of conspiring with
russia to steal our election
was there any evidence of that no none
the most they could do is tell us
that russia was trolling on facebook and
posting memes
that's the most evidence we ever were
given
and this was called rigging the election
they said that trump and russia
conspired to rig the election they then
went on to claim that trump's supreme
court justices were illegitimate
they've been saying that about amy coney
barrett after all of that
you are in simply no position to call
trump a
turtle flailing at the sun unless you
want to call yourself the same
besides anyway the only turtle in
politics is mitch mcconnell and he's
more of a
ninja turtle the guy's a killer he just
doesn't lose mitch mcconnell
by the way hillary clinton in particular
has been on tv for the past four years
calling trump an illegitimate president
those words exactly here she is in 2019
three years after
the election still calling trump an
illegitimate president
listen i believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did
and i take responsibility for those
parts of it that i should but jane it
was like applying for a job and getting
66 million letters of
recommendation and losing to a corrupt
human tornado
and so i know that he knows that
this wasn't on the level i don't know
that we'll ever know everything that
happened but
clearly we know a lot and are learning
more every day and
history will probably sort it all out so
of course he's obsessed with me
and okay now trump is going to say the
same thing about biden
and we're going to have to listen to the
people who cheered hillary clinton
react with feigned shock and horror when
trump says
the same thing hillary clinton said
speaking of which um
here's something i'm wondering i wonder
throughout the past four years of
leftists
calling trump illegitimate calling his
supreme court picks illegitimate
advancing baseless claims of stolen
elections and election rigging and voter
suppression
has any leftist at any point anywhere
ever
been flagged censored or suspended by
twitter facebook any other big tech
company
has there been even one example at one
among the millions of
of cases of this have any of them been
punished by twitter or facebook any of
the rest no of course not
meanwhile nearly everything trump is
currently tweeting is censored by by
twitter
it's completely absurd dishonest double
standards it's wrong
period obviously